how arrogant are you to think that you
deserve to go through life with no one
ever saying anything that you don't
agree with or like I want people to stop
saying that joke's offensive yeah I
wanted to start saying I found it
offensive because you've got our own the
emotion because that's all it is you're
just telling me how you feel about it
yeah there's nothing intrinsically
offensive about this joke but people
then they go uh wow um yeah we shouldn't
hurt people's feelings well you can if
their feelings are wrong yeah yeah if
you don't like the facts get yeah don't
change the fact change the feelings yeah
you don't have to pay the jungle yeah
you can just grow a pair and have a
laugh about